the next time that I had to take my shot
I wanted to go out and do it I didn't
want to be afraid I wanted to conquer my
fear and say yes and this served me
really well a year or so later when I
had to make the really tough decision do
I take this job that I always wanted I
had these high paying job opportunities
$80 to $100,000 starting salary with the
companies that I really wanted to go at
or continue with my startup that was
failing that was making $300 a month I
didn't want to live with the regret of
not knowing what happened with my
business and so I gave myself a year to
say I'm going to push off those jobs
they'll still be there in a year even if
it's not those jobs it's some other job
I'm going to give this a shock I can
deal with the failure I could deal with
the rejection I can deal with that not
working out even though that's a really
kind of shortterm intense pain what I
can't deal with is the regret of not
knowing